Donald Trump spoke at CPAC late last
week the Conservative Political Action
Conference in the speech he said that
media should not be allowed to use
anonymous sources here's what he said
but I am only against the fake news
media or press fake fake they have to
leave that word I'm against the people
that make up stories and make up sources
they shouldn't be allowed to use sources
unless they use somebody's name let
their name be put out there let them
name be put out this is incredibly
dangerous now my analysis that follows
is only for the thinking people ok if
you're a low information Trumpets just
skip the rest of the story it's not
going to resonate for you it's not going
to matter we know too many trumpets are
committed to this abortion of an
administration no matter what but here
is the analysis for the thinking people
Trump says no anonymous sources they're
bad they're terrible they're the worst
the Hillary Clinton emails came from
anonymous sources at least for a while
they were anonymous and Trump loved it
arguably one because of it talked about
the contents of those anonymously leaked
documents all the time the entire
birther lunacy about Barack Obama that
Trump trumped four years was based on
unknown sources Trump saying endlessly a
lot of people don't think that the birth
certificate is authentic
he himself tweeted about it saying for
example an extremely credible source has
called my office and told me that Barack
Obama's birth certificate is a fraud
anonymous source another anonymous
source tweet from Trump sources inside
Attorney General General Schneiderman's
office are saying that they are very
concerned with the allegations against
their lightweight boss I could go on all
day let's pretend I gave you ten more
examples of trump referencing anonymous
sources you get the point I want to get
to the key issue this entire fake news
and anonymous sources and the media is
bad thing is incredibly serious because
it's creating a really dangerous pretext
I was thinking about this over the
weekend
been widely discussed how absurd it is
that Trump referring to the Russia leaks
claiming the the leaks are real but the
news is fake without explaining the
difference what is fake news and what is
a leak leaks are illegal by law right
this is why people like Chelsea Manning
and Edward Snowden get charged with
crimes the sharing of information that
they're forbidden from sharing now
whether you agree with it or not it
doesn't matter the law is what matters
in these cases Chelsea Manning exposed
crimes so I believe that Manning really
is a whistleblower of crimes not a
leaker on the other hand Edward Snowden
exposed deplorable and faulty policy
that was not criminal by statute but
these are in the sort of general sense
leaks okay Donald Trump says the media
shouldn't be allowed to use anonymous
sources this is priming and I've used
the term before Donald Trump is priming
his base too in their low information
confusion equate journalists who use
anonymous sources with leakers who are
committing crimes
I can't imagine Trump came up with this
pad it sounds much more the likes of
Steve Bannon because it's evil genius in
many ways if you blur the lines between
leakers and journalists using anonymous
sources a widely accepted practice in
journalism history reporters will not
want to report on something when their
own name is on the line and be subjected
to prosecution or persecution and the
leakers themselves will be less willing
to talk to the press because the press
will want to name them as sources so
that they wouldn't compromise themselves
if there's this anti anonymous source
mentality what Donald Trump is doing by
blurring these lines is very dangerous
particularly when you know and I know
some of our audience knows some of it
doesn't because they don't care to know
about it that this is a deliberate
attempt to blur the lines between
anonymous sources that are informing
journalists and the act of illegally
leaking private and classified
information I think we also need to
understand what
he means when he said they says they
shouldn't be allowed to report on
anonymous sources yeah because that
could mean anything from they should
have higher journalistic standards and
the media outlets should have this
policy where they don't allow anonymous
sources philosophy could be or it could
be lawsuits the jail tracking down on
anonymous sources and it's just one of
those instances where Trump being vague
does a real disservice to the American
public and the the vagueness Trump may
be vague because he's clueless but the
vagueness of whoever came up with this
idea whether it's Bannon or whoever of
starting to blur the lines between
anonymous journalism sources and leakers
that's part of what makes it so
dangerous okay so don't get confused
it's Trump probably is clueless about
this but either way he's pushing a very
very dangerous narrative a blurring of
lines that we should all be very worried
about